today we are drawing characters in our
own style from the wheel from the wheel
Erik onyx styles random characters it's
been a big wheel see we get alright
Jackie give it a spin alright I can do
princess feet okay do you watch one push
man I do I've never seen frozen just
trust your gut okay let's do it we have
not seen a lot of Simpsons I feel like I
watched Simpsons but like like
peripherally are you of Mario fan yes I
love Mario games I love you Mario Kart
all the way okay so I'm going to
actually try not looking at the
reference so I want this to be a print
original drawing I definitely want her
to have a giant head I wouldn't say that
she didn't have a giant head but I'm
going okay good but I think I'm gonna
keep all her coloring the same
he's got cute big blue hair right she
looks like she's having a really good
time just being a mom okay what did she
do
does she have his mom just she's a
stay-at-home mom that's her thing yeah
love that she's your bliss Marge when I
was a kid I was like addicted to the you
know the nineties era of comic books
where everyone had like unrealistic
proportions as a cartoonist I would say
my style is pretty cartoony but based on
solid illustrative construction so like
I'm not doing a whole lot of
exaggeration in terms of the proportions
he is so iconic and perfect like he's a
good blend of simple but incredibly
memorable he's got his red white blue
colors his overalls his adorable
mustache
big-nose pack his shapes are so good so
I just kind of make a little cartoon
here like cuter cartoony er how did I
develop my style I watched a lot of
anime really just so much of it you say
it's anime influence yeah pretty much
yeah I love anime
still do you're gonna redesign Peach's
dress in any way yes does Princess Peach
like have a sword bro my man it's in
your style Jason okay do whatever you
want
draw her with a sword eleven minutes
okay that's quite not a lot of time if
you like but you know what I believe in
us I believe I'm moving on to inking
inking already Jackie I noticed when you
ink you use coloured lines I do that's
one of my favorite things to do with
lines his color is that an animator
thing I don't think so I think that's
just something I like learned as like a
teenager and then I continue to do cuz I
like the results of them did you grow up
drawing digitally yes I sure did really
yeah I'm not that great with traditional
art really yeah but I mean I can do it
but not as good as I can do things
digitally hmm I rarely color my lines
because again I come from the world of
print and so I'm always thinking about
what is going to make the cleanest black
line yes I respect that I respect your
artistic upbringing
okay I respect your need for speed man
yeah I feel like I don't have much of a
style like I feel like it's definitely
like 90s cartoon inspired like they have
a lot of construction like in terms of
like shapes and like form but then like
I also like to just like throw in weird
perspective things that don't make sense
I can describe cura style very well it
is very clean it's amazing she has
amazing arcs of motion you always choose
to like keep things within not
monochromatic but
like within one minute color limited
like a limited color palette yeah
that's animation way Z style I'm just
getting familiar with today even though
I've known you for a while
cuz you never draw but um your style is
adorable it completely has like that
mascot appeal like that adorable
Japanese mascot appeal who should he be
punching maybe he's punching my Bugs
Bunny I was just about to say that and
happy you are I wrote it up for a bit of
like followed this series they will know
what I'm drawing and it's my disgusting
attempt at a Bugs Bunny I would say if
you really want to get into animation
just draw all the time just like you
know bring a sketchbook with you
anywhere watch youtube videos like
there's so many available resources to
learn you can look up anything in like
super specific and just be like I want
to learn how to draw this or this style
or draw like this you know Disney like
animator
you can just go find and they probably
have like classes online or their own
website or blog or whatever that you can
go yeah look at that's pretty amazing I
should have done a lot simpler of a
design you know what because my style is
complicated just like you write as a
person you know you you've got a lot of
different feelings a lot of different
emotions mm-hmm your art style reflects
who you are she's so cute like I like
her because she's like she's a feminine
woman but she's not like I'm just gonna
sit around and like waetford Mario to do
everything for me it's like she will
take things into her own hands if she
asked him like she goes it's a good role
model yeah so what does Princess Peach
are doing and you're drying she's
holding a sword in her her hair is just
being really epic right now okay
yeah so I'm having a lot of fun with the
just the lines on the hair I'm having
fun beating up my own drawing that's
probably my favorite part it is two more
minutes
[Music]
I just feel like that's quite rude I
forgot her crown this is a trap she's a
princess alright I'm satisfied I didn't
give her any skin color oh it was gonna
be snow white done I think I did pretty
darn good working off of a reference
picture sure makes a lot easier to just
sort of concentrate on the drawing
itself I think I did okay I think she
looks like Shira meets Princess Peach is
what I drew so little wonky okay but I
think the energy of it is cute I think
mine has Elsa vibes I'm not totally
happy with the pose I would say I can do
better
you've got it come on this is great I
love this I love this here's what I love
about yours she's got like a nice line
of action I love her smile dude this is
wild
I love you you got this like epic comic
book perspective on all your drawings
coming at me dude I'm feeling descent
dude you got her like hair which is sort
of mimicking the motion of the flames I
feel her like vengeance you know I like
that he's punching out your Bugs Bunny's
tooth the blood and the blood on this is
great I think you really did reimagine
him like it's clearly him but then it's
like this is cool I can see the cura in
it with the like of the clean lines but
actually this is kind of different I
think for you like I love it thank you
so much for that good job yours is so
adorable I love like the flow of her
shape and I love that she's like tiny
she's so cute I think like the colors
stand out super well you got a you got a
smirk you got her ice magic it's very
pretty
you got our cute little cape you got a
cute little dress yeah but a good job
this exercise was really hard cuz it's
like how do you improve upon characters
that are like the embodiment of
perfection like their designs are so
iconic and so ingrained in our culture
that it's like it's really hard to try
to come up with like a different
appealing interpretation of them
I think that's the most fun part of
drawing fan art is that you can make
your own interpretation on something you
love as a little homage
[Music]
you